[Music]
the siren cries out for 73 seconds
one for each year since what
palestinians call the catastrophe
al-nakba may the 15th
the day after the state of israel was
born
and in the eyes of palestinians when
their dreams died
it's an annual moment of grief and
protest
with emotions particularly high this
year because of the nakba
today like things are going more
more complicated and stuff like that and
will you keep on protesting
yeah sure yeah we'll keep protesting at
protesting until we're free
in ramallah on the west bank anger also
expressed more forcefully
[Applause]
it triggers tear gas in return from
israeli soldiers
a jewish legal attempt to evict some
palestinians from the neighborhood
help trigger the crisis diplomatic
efforts are underway to halt the carnage
but this professor isn't optimistic i
think it's very important to save lives
immediately however
i'm i also realized from my former
experience with what happened in the
past
that after this ends
um probably nothing will change
back on the west bank fury burns
even if the leaders on both sides agree
to some kind of ceasefire
however unlikely that might seem right
now it'll do
nothing to cease the sense of suffering
and rage
felt by the path to a lasting peace
all but impossible to see debra haynes
sky news ramallah